Còn qua bùng 3 tháng 18,000 năm 2018, trên cú lộ 20,000 điều phần sạch gây bà đất lắc,
sẻ ra vụ tên an zothong khiến một lãi đạo sạch đăng làm nhiệm vụ tử vòng.
Thế đó, tôi cùng ngày, trên địa bàn sạch gây bà xe ra ngồi lớn khiến một đảng cú lộ 20,000 đặc sâu.
Chứ tình như trên, đồng chi lế phức tỏan bống mấy tư tuổi, chú tịch i banh như sạch gây bà, cùng một số cán mộ.
Thình viên của i banh như sạch có mặt tại hiện chừng đủ trực tiếp vình luật hướng sát thông,
nhằm đảm bảo an toàn trong người dân qua khu vực viềm, trong quá trình làm nhiệm vụ,
đồng chi tản bất ngờ bị một sèo tù con tổ chúng,
mặc dù được mọi người nhé nhé trong đưa đế bệnh biển cấp hướng,
nhưng giờ vết thường quán nạch đồng chi tản đã khu qua khòa.
Muy nhiên vụ tên an đăng đặc được các quan chức năng đều tra, làm sao?